- [Lecturer] In this
video, we're gonna talk
about cell division and organism growth.
Or another way to think about it is,
how do we start with fertilization?
And we talk about this in other videos,
but in sexually reproducing species,
each individual starts off as a cell
that is the result of the fusion
between a sperm and an
egg, between two gametes.
And each of these gametes have half
of the genetic material
needed to make that organism.
So once they fuse, once the
fertilization has happened,
you are now diploid.
So you're haploid when you have half
of the genetic material, as
each of these individually
have each of these gametes,
and then you become
diploid once it's fused.
Well, once it's fused, that fertilized egg
will then start to divide and replicate.
And so a short period of time later,
you might have eight cells
that has divided in two,
it'll first divide into two,
then those two will become four,
those four will become eight,
the eight will become 16,
and you keep dividing,
and before you know it,
you have trillions of cells
on the order of 30 to 40 trillion
and you could create this
very handsome organism
right over here.
But an interesting question is,
how does that division happen?
And are the cells identical?
Do they have the same
identical genetic material?
But if they are, how do they differentiate
into all of the different types of cells
that make this handsome organism?
The skin cells versus the heart cells
versus the nerve cells?
And this process of cell division
in which a parent cell divides
into two new daughter cells,
each of which is genetically
identical to the parent cell,
is known as mitosis.
And so let's dig into
mitosis a little bit.
So let's start with two daughter cells
from a previous round of mitosis.
Now, this would not be a human cell.
What we're looking at is four
chromosomes in two pairs.
And the way that they've color-coded it,
two of these are blue
and two of these are red.
While a human cell would have
23 pairs or 46 chromosomes,
but this is a eukaryotic cell.
The genetic material is inside
of the nucleus right over here.
And just to understand what
these long strands are,
these are chromosomes in
their non-condensed form.
And a chromosome you can really view
as a long strand of DNA,
and you're going to have
segments of that DNA
that code for specific proteins,
and those segments are what we call genes.
In a given chromosome pair,
you will code for the same genes,
but you might have different
versions of the same gene.
Maybe this gene right over here
contributes to hair color in some way,
and then this other one
contributes in the same way,
but it might lead to a
different hair color.
So each of these chromosomes in a pair,
we call them homologous
or homologous pairs.
They're coding for the same genes.
They're the same set of genes,
but they might have different versions
of those genes or different alleles.
So that's what we're seeing here.
Now to prepare for mitosis,
what we need to see
is each of these chromosomes
need to replicate,
and once they do, the
cell might look like this.
Now it's hard to see it here,
but the two copies that are now replicated
and connected at the center,
we call them sister chromatids.
And we can see that a little bit clearer
in the early phases of mitosis.
So first, we see that the chromosomes
have condensed into what
we classically imagine
as chromosomes when we look
at it into a microscope.
This is really happening
in preparation for mitosis,
in preparation for cell division.
And so you see those two homologous pairs,
and you can see each of those chromosomes
actually now consists of
two sister chromatids,
one over here, one over there.
As we go through mitosis,
they're going to separate
into individual chromosomes
that are actually just
copies of each other.
Now, the other thing that we're seeing
in this early phase of mitosis
is that the nuclear envelope
starts to break down,
and we're gonna see why that's important,
because we're gonna have to
separate the chromosomes.
Now, the other thing that we see,
and in other future biology classes
you'll go into much more detail,
is the mitotic spindle
is starting to form.
Now, we don't have to
go into all the details
of the different parts
of the mitotic spindle,
but imagine a bunch of structures
made primarily by protein
that are actually going to act to allow
the mitosis to happen,
to grab the chromosomes,
to pull them apart, to allow
the cell to change its shape
so that it will eventually
be able to divide.
But after that, we go into
the middle phase of mitosis.
So as we enter into the
middle phases of mitosis,
we can see now that the chromosomes
are aligned at the center,
and they've actually now been attached
to the mitotic spindle, which
is going to be important,
because that's the machinery
that's going to pull them apart
and bring them to the
different sides of the cell.
And as we continue through
the middle phases of mitosis,
we see that right over there,
that those sister chromatids
are now pulled apart
and they are copies of each other.
They became copies of
each other back here,
where the DNA originally replicated
when it wasn't in its condensed form.
But I think you see where this is going.
As the mitotic spindle
pulls on these chromosomes,
we then enter into the
late phases of mitosis.
And you can see here that
the sister chromatids,
which are now individual chromosomes,
have been pulled to either side
of that now elongated cell.
You can see that once they're there,
a nuclear envelope begins to
form again on either side,
and then the mitotic spindle breaks down
and the splitting of the cytoplasm finally
into two daughter cells
is known as cytokinesis.
So it's pretty mind boggling to realize
that this is going on in
your body continuously,
and this is what allowed
all of us to start
as a single-celled
organism, a fertilized egg,
and become an organism made
of tens of trillions of cells.
Now, I haven't gone into detail yet.
Even though the great
majority of our cells
have the exact same genetics,
they are actually able to differentiate,
express different parts of the genetics
based on the roles that they need to play,
but we will talk about
that in future videos.
It's also important to realize
that mitosis isn't just
about growing an organism.
It's also about maintaining an organism
and doing tissue repair for an organism.
So I'll leave you there.
Look at your hands, look at your arms,
look in the mirror and just realize
that you are an organism
of 30 to 40 trillion cells
that all started with one cell
through many, many,
many rounds of mitosis.